Hey everybody!
This is Sona.
You know, I thought it would
be a good idea to check in.
And I hope you're all staying safe
and distancing yourselves
socially from one another.
I'm having a great time.
Let's see, I got a blow out.
Which I realize was probably
a little irresponsible
but I would've lost 50% of the
payment had I not gone.
And in my defense, this
blood is days and days old.
I haven't washed my hair
in a really long time.
So I just moved into my house
like a little while ago.
My husband and I bought a house
and I know that on Sona Fixes Your Life
I once told you guys
that my parents wanted
to throw all my speech trophies
because they thought it was
they were taking up too much space.
'Cause I have too many.
And I thought that they did but then
my mom gave me this, which is basically
a lot of my childhood is in here.
And I looked at it the other day.
And look what I found!
All my speech trophies.
PSCFA Spring Championship
Senior Duo Interpretation,
second place.
But, that's fine.
You know, and then there's this one.
Third place.
Okay we'll find one, some good ones.
And there's this one that's all broken.
That's first place.
PSCFA Fall Championship
Senior Speech to Entertain,
first place.
And then there's all these.
Here's the problem.
And they're all broken.
The problem is
is that when my mom and dad
were holding on to this stuff,
I didn't really care.
But now that it's in my house,
I don't want them.
So I think that
my mom's idea was I take a
photo shoot with all of these,
and then just take a picture
to remember all of them.
And I
I think I'm going to do that today.
So I think today in my home,
I'm going to force my poor husband
to help me with the photo
shoot with all these,
and then I'm going to throw 'em away.
Unless you guys want them
'cause I don't.
First place.
Watson-Lancer Speech Tournament.
First place in duo.
Oh my god, there's just so many!
Third place.
This one's small.
I don't even know what this is.
There's no plaque on it.
Anyway so, I'm gonna take a
I'm gonna do a photo shoot today.
Maybe put on a dress
and some makeup for the first
time in a really long time.
And yeah.
We're just gonna say goodbye
to all these trophies today.
And then, I'm probably
gonna go to sleep at like 9?
And wake up at noon?
'Cause that's what I've been doing
for like a week.
Alright.
I think
I think that's it.